[Music]
are you gonna get it how's it all
Cinderella we have some questions for
you Disney what is the deal with all the
characters who don't get happy endings
aren't you in the business of creating
fairy tales credos from villains don't
deserve to live happily ever after but
what about all the good characters that
have terrible endings
sometimes these characters stories and
so Vaali and makes us want to cry not
every Disney character gets to live
happily ever after you know which feel
of a character had the saddest ending of
them all keep watching to find out Ariel
from The Little Mermaid at first glance
it might seem like Ariel had a
traditional happily ever after she got
the prince and sailed off into the
sunset but if you look a little bit
deeper you'll see that her story isn't
all done happy Prince Eric only fell in
love with her because of her voice
that's not a great foundation for a
happy marriage plus she turns human all
of her family and friends are still in
the sea she can't ever truly return home
to visit the Zootopia predators the poor
predators in Zootopia went through a
rough time they were kidnapped and
poisoned and the media made them out to
be monsters no he's my friend plus the
rate of prey is growing rapidly and the
predator population is declining there
are plenty of critters who think like
bellwether with their bad rap and the
fact that their population is shrinking
it's a bad time to be a predator it's
only a matter of time before Zootopia is
made up entirely of prey mr. Smee from
Peter Pan when it comes to villains mr.
Smee is the least evil one ever he was
insanely loyal to Captain Hook
he wasn't cruel and he wasn't much of a
fighter he really deserved a much better
life but Captain Hook's actions left his
crew in bad shape they spent the rest of
their lives being chased by the
crocodiles mr. Smee stays with Captain
Hook even though he is treated terribly
mr. Smee deserves so much better
the Fox in the hound the Fox in the
hounds might be the saddest Disney movie
ever made Todd his young Fox who
befriends a hound named Cooper they
become best friends but they are
supposed to be mortal enemies Cooper is
supposed to hunt Todd for his owner in
the end they are separated forever
Cooper stays with his not-so-nice owner
and they can't ever be friends again
since Cooper's owner wants to kill Todd
doesn't that just make you want to hug
your bestie and never let go the ugly
sisters Cinderella's stepsisters were
pretty terrible to her but they had been
raised to be mean they thought they were
supposed to acts like that because their
mother did and let's be honest
Drizella and Anastasia were victims too
their mother held them to impossible
standards she only wanted them to get
married so she could be rich they were
always seen as less pretty and less
smart than Cinderella even by their own
mother Cinderella got away but these two
sisters were stuck with their wicked mom
forever the Hunchback of Notre Dame we
are used to Disney movies that end with
a happy love story but The Hunchback of
Notre Dom totally messes up our idea of
a happily ever after the hero doesn't to
get the girl Quasimodo is so in love
with Esmeralda he nearly dies to save
her but as Marella is in love with
someone else at the end of the movie
Quasimodo accepts this that people see
him as a true hero but he didn't get his
chance at true love or quasi Sid from
Toy Story we can pretty much all agree
that Sid was a terrible kid he was mean
and angry the toys make him out to be a
psychopath but they're forgetting one
thing he's just a child
Sid's dad is absent for some reason it's
been reasonable to assume that Sid has
been through something though and he
takes out his anger and other feelings
on his toys plus he sees toys talking to
him and no one believes him then his
toys all but abandoned him that's just
sad trust
my pungent friend you'll get what's
coming to watch coming Iago from Aladdin
Jafar's parrot was a great spy and
sarcastic sidekick but he was just doing
what his master wanted he wasn't evil
and Jafar was mean to him
I think end of Aladdin he is cursed to
stay in the lamp with Jafar that's not
fair
he escapes and turns good in return of
Jafar he becomes loyal to aladdin and
Jasmine but then they go off to travel
the world leaving a Yago at the palace
without any friends Maleficent the
mistress of all evil is one of Disney's
greatest villains in the original
Sleeping Beauty she falls to her death
but Disney revealed in the live-action
Maleficent that she wasn't all that evil
she was trying to save her people and if
you take descendants as canon Maleficent
had a way worst ending the last time we
saw her on the Disney Channel movie she
was stuck as a lizard that's a terrible
fate bing-bong from inside outs no
characters ending was as sad as Bing
bongs
Bing bong was Riley's imaginary friend
he is in danger of being forgotten as
she gets older he was happy and sweet
and he helps protect Riley's memories
but then he sacrifices himself to save
joy he is literally wiped out of Riley's
memory forever he ceases to exist and we
think he deserved so much better which
Disney characters do you think deserved
a happy ending let us know in the
comments Disney characters who didn't
get their happy ending thanks for
watching if you love all things Disney
subscribe to the things for more great
content and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll see you next
time
[Music]